Maggie's in Georgia hey Maggie welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave thanks
so much for having me sure what's up so
my husband and I got married back in
December and we just recently started
listening to the show about a month ago
and are a little bit overwhelmed because
we owe around 450,000 or were 450,000
and debt 180,000 is his pharmacy school
student loans 18,000 is one car that we
have and then we just purchased a
250,000 dollar how like two weeks ago
so we're overwhelmed and don't really
know what to do so I thought well let me
call the Dave Ramsey show it said if he
has any advice what's your household
income we bring home right around 135 so
you're not working outside the home
I yes I am socially employed pharmacist
then well we grossed around 170 and then
we bring home 130 okay I'm sorry I
misunderstood now you're so 170 all
right mm-hmm
well a hundred and eighty thousand
dollars should scare the pants off of
you it does it scare you need to start
acting like that and quit buying crap
mm-hm if you were really scared you
wouldn't bought this house no you're
right if you're really scared you
wouldn't about this car
so you equip buying stuff you know tight
budget and live like somebody that makes
$50,000 a year okay no life no vacations
you don't get to see the inside of a
restaurant unless you're working there
as your side hustle
okay scorched earth if you'll do that
you can clean this mess up
pretty quick without selling without
selling the house what about the car I'd
keep the car it's not killing me here
but you're going to have to you know
you're gonna have a shock to your system
and people around you are gonna make fun
of you and wonder if you've lost your
mind
you're gonna cut your lifestyle that far
mm-hmm otherwise you're gonna wallow in
this for a decade right
but if you I could get if I could get
you to act like you live on 50000 and
you put 75 to $100,000 a year towards
the debt you're out of debt in about
three years not counting the house that
way well 75 times three is two ten
seventy times ten is ten and so um you
know no more 401k investing you're not
doing anything except chunking big hairy
payments on this stuff and you can do it
that way or you can take 15 years and
wallow in this which is what most people
don't want to do that's what most people
do though isn't it
it is well and it's a mindset shift from
I felt like I was going to be in debt
the rest of my life you're listening to
the show and thinking wait we don't have
to be in debt forever we actually write
news is the great news is you're in a
you have a really big shuffle I mean you
make a hundred and seventy thousand
dollars a year as a young married couple
that's pretty impressive
the bad news is you're in a really big
hole with this nice shovel so you got
you can put the you got a big enough
shovel to dig your way out but you're
gonna have to shock your system and I
mean there is nothing gonna be purchased
at your house you're gonna live like
broke college students because you are
broke college students if you'll do that
you can turn this around pretty quick
kiddo
and we'll be here to help you you call
me I'll encourage you i'll lovingly fuss
at you as mean ol Uncle Dave but I'll
encourage you to I think you can do this
you sound like smart people to me
you did some dumb stuff you can turn it
around